today
hey what's up guys welcome BHD here and
welcome back to a very busy techtober
near in the end but nowhere near done
this time we're coming at you with the
brand new iPhone 10r you didn't forget
about this one did you
so the iPhone 10s and 10s Max came out a
couple weeks ago and now they're
incoming slightly cheaper 750 iPhone 10r
is starting to ship this is the 256 gig
Red version but here's the thing the
unboxing experience is mostly the same
as the iPhone 10s so if you dig in you
get your paperwork at the top as you
expect a little red tab reveals the
Apple stickers and your quick start
guide and everything and since this is a
product red phone that is donating to
Abe's research and supporting the
product red program you do get a little
red pamphlet but as far as I know the
other colored iPhones don't have a
colored pamphlet and then underneath
that the rest of the accessories so the
slow charging brick the lightning cable
and the lightning headphones and the
missing dongle all of that the same as
the iPhone 10s which means really the
only different thing is the phone in the
Box
and yet this thing is so red it's as far
as I can tell the same red as that last
year product red iPhone 8 that I was
raving over so the Ferrari red the rich
red the Tesla surfboard red it's so
bright I love it so things I will be
testing for my full review that are
definitely different from iPhone 10s as
far as I know the new screen so the sub
720p LCD that's made all the news the
ram technically iPhone 10r has one gig
less of ram than the 10s so three gigs
here this slightly different material
choices so this 10r has colored aluminum
rails instead of the stainless steel so
it's matte instead of glossy and it
feels a little bit lighter the single
camera and the color I don't even have
to test the color really but officially
it is different so you got to mention it
but the main difference really being the
screen and I'll be digging into that
pretty deep seeing if this panel is as
good as Apple says or as bad as some
YouTube videos would have you believe
and if anything else comes up during the
full review process that will be
mentioned too but that's what we know
for sure is different anyway that's
pretty much it I guess since this is a
pretty short video and there's not a
whole lot else to it I guess we might as
well toss in a little giveaway shall we
so officially here's what we'll do I'm
going to give away one iPhone 10r to
someone one of you watching this video
right now all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment below of
which color you'd want remember there's
six of them right so black white red
coral blue or yellow one of those
naturally this video might bias you a
little bit since the red is just so
gorgeous even in video but that's up to
you you can pick the color and I'll
announce the winner on Twitter in one
week so seven days from now to the hour
you guys will know exactly who's gonna
win I'll retype everything down below in
the description below that like button
just so we have it all clear we're all
on the same page it's International
anyone with a shipping address on planet
Earth that I can get to is eligible to
win
that's pretty much it best of luck and
that's it for this quick one thanks for
watching catch you guys later peace